intanto il rumore non meno il rapporto
si fa abbastanza roma
[Musica]
oggi a grandissima richiesta tornano ne
sai con tre parole non mi sono giocato
ho visto che il barca non c'è cartellino
se questo video raggiunge dissimile
bisogno si assisterà a un altro bisogni
tre palloni per me rally challenge con i
personaggi che considerate voi nei
commenti quindi scrivete subito un
commento con il personaggio problema che
corriamo le regole del gioco sono
facilissime pagheremo tre colori da qua
a caso dovremo correre ai nostri
personaggi per ogni turno voi dovrete
votare chi vince 6 vinco io agosto e
bill shope ideale per ogni round alla
fine sommeremo i punti a vedremo
stravinto in una talentuosa vito vitale
in base ai vostri voti siete pronti
professor odifreddi bastare i primi
round il nostro primo personaggio
sarebbe un atto primo personaggio
abbiamo il trench orchestrano chissà
come uscirà il grinch non verde oggi ti
sei vestito da grains tra l'albero
dubbio detto che ho comprato dei
nuovissimi pennarelli quindi abbiamo
molti bicolore
io volevo fare un po di rumore
ho scelto mesto marrone è
il mio preferito rosa il riccioluto di
teheran grinch femmina toccate
come saprete sanità
lilla wow sia proprio un grigio è molto
delicata tocca al milan fa tanto rumore
non meno il rapporto si trova abbastanza
rumore
ho scelto
acqua
maglietta è vero basta poi perderlo è
vero
piano quando peschi
rosso pd o rosa lilla è rotto ma dove
c'è più bello il mio facciamo vedremo
dovrete dare ai premi a chi vince tutto
rosa o tutto viola
perfetto scritto io cambio subito colori
allora facciamo gli occhi cattivissimi
ok pronto allora prima il grigio e di
vitale vediamo proprie mura 23 e
arancione verde ma dov'è il terzo colore
v sul petto vicino agli occhi negli
occhi sul naso socio offerto qua sotto e
anche sulla pancia di fatto tipo tipo
insieme dell'avvocato a pancia in su
visi nota ed è già il mio grizzo invece
rosa viola con gli stivali rossi
vediamoli tutto il mio fianco e scrivete
invece il primo round grigio di anita o
grigio di vitale scrivete nel cu me ne
andrò
secondo noi dobbiamo baldi tappe scoprì
ma io argenti e una mela mescolata
giusto per fare un po di rumore
rumore
arancioni chiaro che potrebbe star bene
con baldi
rosa con arm e balli e roccia
piccolo ne prendi
prua chiamiamo questo blu è più bello
come diete e questo non è blu e viola è
un viola blu blu violetto viola blu
violetto questo bellissimo
potevo prendere io
è stata un po di rumore
novità pure
l non so se fare baldi blu o
arancione forse blu è troppo scuro
quindi posso fare baldi arancioni chiaro
vediamo come esce al rispetto momento ma
qual è il colore di baldi rosso o giallo
nel giallo che vedevi come che supererà
anche ranieri e mobilitano trovati
allora maglietta blu maniche verbi
questa volta mi sono capitati colori un
po scuri quindi sembra un po scuro come
colore sono testa di
zucchero sembra un po una zucca vediamo
quello di vita ed ha
mai fatto una maglietta
coloratissima questo fa paura
che la scritta baldi votate chi vince
per il secondo round quale baldi vince
basi di anita baldi di vitale scrivete
nei commenti devo dire che a me piace il
baldi di vitale più colorato a più
colori hai fatto bene a fare la maestra
strisce molto fieri grazie a me a me del
tuo piace la testa la testa di zucca
ribadire come che facciamo al terzo rai
2 1
abbiamo occhi si
no mi è cascato e giustamente chi si
visse di casa vita il blu quindi sarà
una vittima e un po anche
lì la lila
preso giorno
lessi vissi
viola scuro
lilla e viola fu
lui facciamo scambio come se facciamo
scoperto che ben il
rosso
verde
unione
prodi
allora faccio chi si misti lilla e
uscirà bellissima secondo me io invece
la farò ciarla mature viola scuro e
verde facciamo le mani piedi
wow web è una delle più belle ha
iniziato prima non mi ricordo io ok
vediamo per evitare
che ora vi piace sembra chisti misi
uscita dai
sera è bellissima gialla con le labbra
rosse ei guanti cioè i piedi e le zampe
si blu ero troppo felice infatti di come
uscire troppo bella bellissima
persona per un milione viola con
sfumature viola scuro e la bocca e le
zampe verdi sku mi piacciono molto le
sfumature troppo carina nera se prendo
così carini tutti i suoi rivediamoci
votate tra i due terzo round chi vince
chi ti micidialità hawkins missiva
votate nei commenti e ora
ultim'ora pronti per l'ultimo round 3 2
buratto
paura non poteva non mancare al di
luoghi comuni la signora sara arrivati
pronti a pescare in
questo verde mi
sta che tira un bel laghi white tutto
verde
ci saranno stand up e c'hanno sera il
suo non è chiaro se non lo so ora sono
solo se va bene
viola
viola stampa
[Musica]
no mi è caduto ma ho preso questo atteso
the e uno sia w ai tre colori trani e
fucsia viola se ci sono
grandi come
principale non so se parlo rosso tutto
rosso questo
geniale farò tipo una fiamma non so se
riuscirà a fermarci provo video e per il
gran finale
allora vediamo il primario guardie
allora l'effetto fiamma c'è un ciao è un
po strano però il mi piace molto devo
dire però ho cercato di fare di
colorando in modo che sembrate qua una
fiamma in più fa più paura del solito
lavoro di vita a lei piace tanto
soprattutto l'effetto fuoco quando
è uscito benissimo tu l'hai colorato
tutto pieno e fa un bellissimo aspetto
questo verde viola e rosa quindi per
l'ultimo round votate chi vince quarto e
ultimo round a di vuoti di anita oa di
wadi di vitale avete votato tutti e ora
vi diremo secondo non è qual è stato il
più bello di tutti e quando mai più
bello è stata questa kitty mi ha chiuso
dotare bellissima si auto voti
ma è il vincitore tra tutti e questo
brevetto secondo me quell'estate più
usati tutti massa dub rinviate è ora vi
lasciamo 4 adesso linz complicare per
vedere i nostri altri video legate a
scuola che preferite